uh what's it like you know i think yo
gotti is rivaling
gucci mane as
the best hip-hop a r in the last like 20
years because i think gucci's
if you just think of all the people who
he's helped start their career whether
they were signing him or not i think
he's the goat when it comes to just his
ear and the a r [ __ ] but god he's right
there
cmg is becoming like a
[ __ ] empire it's really dope to see
what is it like kind of having him
you know as a mentor as somebody who you
could call on you know he's you know i
respect the [ __ ] out of gotti so what's
that like
it's like
basically
it's like everything really because like
if i need
advice on anything i know that he hasn't
been through everything like he didn't
had he had ups and downs with the music
so he know
how to jump jump back so that's why i
asked him for everything
that's dope yeah he's a man like
and you know what's crazy is i remember
i was in the studio with gotti a couple
of years ago and he was like on
soundcloud like trying to find [ __ ] like
new artists and [ __ ]
like he's got his like he's super tapped
in ear to the street [ __ ]